you have to make a decision one way or
another because you're either going to
take the mephistophilian route and say
you know life is so terrible that it
should just come to an end and that if
there is a God he should be damned for
having the presumption to make such a
terrible world or you're going to say no
despite everything I'm going to work in
all possible ways to make everything
better and to tell the truth while
moving forward and I'm going to conduct
my life according to those principles
and then I'm going to have the adventure
that comes along with that and see what
happens that's what the scientific
atheist does not understand I think that
there are some truths that you cannot
simply discover you have to live them
you have to make the experiment
uh I think of kindergarten's night of
Faith from the Viewpoint of Juliet Here
Comes Romeo with no guarantees he does
not bring an uh an array of lawyers and
philosophers to persuade her that it is
utterly rational for her to elope with
him he says leap into my arms
and she does not know whether that will
end well or not
uh it it's an Act of Faith it's a leap
and in the play of course it doesn't pay
off they both die or you might say that
even even that since it was on in a
sense a noble death was a payoff but uh
but there's no guarantee that's that's
why there's faith
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone I have the great pleasure
today to be talking to
Dr Peter krieft
Peter John krieft was born March 16 1937
he's a professor of philosophy at Boston
College and the King's College
he took his a b at Calvin College in
1959 and an M.A at Fordham University in
where he also undertook his doctoral
studies in 1965.
he subsequently completed his post-grad
at Yale University
Dr kreef joined the philosophy faculty
of the Department of philosophy of
Boston College
in 1965.
a convert to Roman Catholicism Dr kreef
is the author
of over 80 books
on Christian philosophy Theology and
apologetics we're going to discuss
religious issues in the modern world
today with some foray into the
relationship between the abrahamic
faiths
particularly Islam
Dr krieff welcome thank you very much
for agreeing to talk to me today
I have the same to say to you thank you
very much for agreeing to talk to me
today
so some of the things we're doing
seem to be somewhat similar I'm very
interested in
religious ideas and practices uh I'm
very interested in the idea that such
beliefs and practices sit at the
foundation of the web of beliefs through
which we view the world and you're an
Unapologetic advocate of traditional
beliefs in a world that seems
increasingly distant from them and
skeptical of them I guess what I'd like
to know first of all is your your books
follow a thread what do you think the
thread is that that that unites your
work and what is it that you're trying
to accomplish and why I know that's not
an easy question
well I'll give you a very concrete
answer one of my favorite books is
chesterton's book on Thomas Aquinas
called St Thomas Aquinas the Del Marx
and the main point of that book is that
This brilliant Theologian and
philosopher is the champion of Common
Sense
that uh the rising of the intellect to
uh the contemplation of Eternal truth on
the one hand and practical living out
Common Sense tradition on the other hand
are not only not opposites they
reinforce each other
so I think our common respect for
tradition is also a respect for for
common sense
which is why I admire your work
so you wrote a book on uh uh Jake
Jacob's Ladder and and I recently went
to New York and saw these ideas don't
seem related but they are I saw
Wagner's guy Meister singer and in that
Opera
which is about cobblers interestingly
enough shoemakers so very very practical
people the Great
cobblers are part of a guild and the
greatest of the Cobblers become singers
and the master singers from all the
guilds get together and elect
a new master singer and that Master
singer that is elected in this
particular story is a uh analog of
Christ and what I really liked about the
Opera was this idea it's like the brick
layer who's building a cathedral Brick
by Brick each brick is just a brick and
it's and you could be cynical about the
smallness of the task in some sense but
when the brick is conceptualized in
relationship to the entire Cathedral
then it becomes a task where the lowest
is united with the highest
and I think that's what Jacob's Ladder
signifies conceptually
that there has to be a sequence of
action all the way from the most
concrete tasks to the highest level of
theological abstraction and that has to
be harmoniously arrayed in some manner
that's approximately akin to a symphony
and if that's done properly then even
the most mundane of tasks which aren't
mundane at all take on uh well I would
say in the optimal sense they take on a
kind of Eternal significance and it's in
that Union there of the Practical and
the the highest that that strikes me as
uh germane to what you're describing
about the link between the Practical and
the and the philosophical and the
abstract
yes I love the old story about uh uh
some peasants uh hauling stones on logs
through the mud in a storm in order to
build one of the great medieval
Cathedrals uh and uh a visitor from
another country uh asked one of the uh
peasants what are you doing and he was
sweating and cursing and saying I'm
trying to get this damn stone through
this damn mud and then he asked another
of the peasants who were doing exactly
the same thing but smiling uh what he
was doing and he said I am building a
cathedral
right right right well and it it does
make you think
it like I know from a psychological
perspective that
the emotional functions that fill us
with enthusiasm and hope and also the
emotional functions that quell anxiety
and despair are related to our
apprehension of sequential goals so you
can imagine that we have nested goals
and so might be getting the mud through
or getting the rocks through a swamp and
then getting the rocks to the building
side and then building the foundation
Etc but then it's building the
foundation and having a family and doing
that within a community and then
building a cathedral in relationship to
the highest glory of the of the most
glorious
well we can leave it at that of the most
glorious and then everything along that
chain is imbued with the entire with the
significance of the whole
yes everything is imbued with
significance if and only if you start at
the end of the chain
if there's just as if there's no first
cause there are no subsequent effects so
if there's no Final End there's no
ultimate purpose for doing anything
okay so there's a good thing to delve
into
um so I've been walking through the
Bible recently with a particular goal in
mind and I noticed that that in some of
your books you use characterization as
explanation and so
it looks to me that if we build a
hierarchy of value a hierarchy of
attentional priority that's another way
of looking at it that there's only two
options to how that might be constructed
one is that it has a multitude of ends
and the other is that it has a single
end
now the problem with a hierarchy of
value having a multitude of ends
is that it's internally
self-contradictory and and that has two
psychological consequences one is it
decreases hope and enthusiasm because
the linkage between each goal isn't
associated with something that's at the
highest point but probably more relevant
to today's anxious secularism is that if
there's no unifying superordinate goal
then the state of psychological Affairs
that obtains is one of confusion anxiety
and social disunity now I actually don't
see any options to that so something
something is either put in the highest
place or confusion and anxiety and
hopelessness Reigns those seem to be the
alternative I think that is the
psychological reason why Pagan
polytheism declined and abrahamic
monotheism triumphed we need one great
love to be one great person you can't
integrate your personality around
multiple some emotions multiple greatest
Goods
right well because it does it does
produce this conflict and then you know
you you mentioned the notion of a person
and so I was thinking well what should
be at the highest point is it a
description or is it a spirit and again
I'm trying to speak psychologically and
think well it has to be a spirit and not
a description because maybe you have a
beautiful description of the nature of
the objective world that's something you
might do is if you're a scientist but
that doesn't provide a guide to
perception and action what human beings
need at the highest place is something
to emulate and act out and see through
like you might see through lenses and so
the the the the the the phenomena
the phenomenon that has to be at the
highest place has to be something to
emulate and imitate and therefore it has
to have the nature for all intents and
purposes of a spirit or of a being and
not of a mere description I think there
are a number of people uh especially in
Academia who can live for abstractions
it's the difference between Socrates and
Plato uh Plato believed that the
absolute was the good the good itself
Apparently that is not a God not a
person Socrates was moved and motivated
by his Fidelity to what he called his
unknown God
uh and and most people identify with
Socrates rather than Plato except
perhaps in Academia because abstractions
will not disappoint you uh and they will
not change uh and persons will so the
major objection I believe especially on
the part of people in the orient to uh
abrahamic monotheism is that if God is a
person and concrete then he might
disappoint you he's unpredictable he's
he's a concrete entity rather than an
abstraction abstractions are safe
yeah well the problem with with the
abstraction orientation is that it still
leaves you with the mystery of how to
live and act outside of your obsession
to the abstraction but even more
particularly you know I've I've spent a
fair bit of time speaking with famous
atheists and a number of atheists a very
large number have watched my biblical
lectures and apparently found them
useful which I think is quite
interesting and the the thing about the
atheist crowd in some sense especially
the scientific
scientifically minded atheists like like
Richard Dawkins and Sam Harris is that
I can't help but see that their
scientific Pursuit is nested inside a
spiritual faith that they leave implicit
so Dawkins for example who I respect a
tremendous amount I've read a lot of his
work and I found it very useful Dawkins
clearly believes that there's a
Transcendent object
that you can encounter through the
scientific method that will correct you
because he doesn't believe that his
theories are final he believes that out
in the domain of ignorance in the logos
of the world let's say there is
corrective information and that seeking
that corrective information is a moral
good and he clearly also believes that
the truth will set you free which you
have to believe if you're going to be a
practicing scientist and so I think even
those who presume that they've put an
abstraction that's disembodied in the
highest place are actually wrong
psychologically that there's something
that they are embodying
as Spirits even if it's mimicry of the
great scientists and the scientific
Spirit of inquiry there's something
they're mimicking that serves them as
the highest orientation point and I
can't see how that's not related to the
idea of the logos
yes and if Dawkins has this will to
truth
and without the will of truth without
the love of truth truth is meaningless
uh it may still exist but it doesn't
affect us without that will to Truth uh
his whole world view collapses even his
atheist worldview which is why I think
Nietzsche is the key thinker here
because he is the first
as far as I know in the history of human
thought to explicitly deny the will to
truth he says why truth why not rather
untruth
his contrast between the dionysian and
the apollonian between the of the will
and the mind between the fire and the
light uh that tears the human heart
apart more radically than anything else
I've I think I've ever encountered
so I think I think post-modern
post-modernism is a much greater danger
than atheism because the atheist can
still have that will to truth but the
post-modernist has lost it
we'll have more with Peter Creek in just
a moment but first I want to tell you
about Halo the importance of a routine
cannot be understated just like making
your bed every morning daily prayer
helps you build character and Faith
build this fundamental habit with hallow
the number one Christian Prayer app in
the U.S and the number one Catholic app
in the world hallow is like calm or
headspace but without the new age
principles instead hallow offers
meditations rooted in two thousand years
worth of authentic Christian prayer
practices
hallo has over 5 000 prayers and
meditations including the daily Rosary
Gospel reading and daily Psalm with
Bishop Barron the Bible in a year with
father Mike Schmitz prayers led by Mark
Wahlberg and Jim Caviezel minute
meditations meditations for sleep and
more hallo has prayers and meditations
to guide you throughout your entire day
from morning to night try hallow for
three months free today at hollow.com
Jordan that's hallow.com Jordan
discipline your prayer life with hallow
download it today
yeah well okay so let's go let's go back
let's let's concentrate for a bit on the
Nietzsche in front so when when
Nietzsche announced God was dead he did
it
he did it weirdly enough the same way
that God told Moses in some sense to set
his people free in Egypt so I just did a
seminar on Exodus half a seminar with a
bun with a group of Scholars in Miami
which we're going to release in November
but
God tells Moses to
tell the pharaoh to let his people go
which you hear all the time that phrase
but that's not the whole phrase he says
let my people go so that they may serve
me in the wilderness which is very
different than just let my people go
which is more like a call to maybe even
a hedonistic Freedom when Nietzsche says
that God is dead which is what you see
written on bathroom walls for example
and that's the claim that's trumpeted he
followed that up with an observation
that I'm paraphrasing which is something
like God is dead and we have killed him
the holiest of all that has ever existed
has now bled to death under our knives
and will never find enough water to wash
away the blood
and that's very different than a
triumphal statement that God is dead and
I've been thinking that through on the
atheist materialist front as well and
it's possible and I think Dawkins and
Harris to some degree are experiencing
this in the culture right now is that
when you when you lose that sense of the
Transcendence Spirit let's say that's
more explicitly associated with
religious belief
because God is now dead there's a good
possibility that you lose the
Transcendent object too and so that if
we kill off the judeo-christian or even
the abrahamic tradition under the
onslaught of post-modern criticism we're
also going to simultaneously kill off
scientific inquiry and scientific
Endeavor I think that's inevitable I
agree but there's something more uh
the love of Truth is not enough if truth
doesn't somehow
rebound on you and and love you back if
if if if truth if truth is only an
abstraction and not a person not a
spirit with a will you have theology but
not religion
theology is a one-way relationship
theology is a science I try to
understand the truth about God uh
religion is a two-way relationship
so God's initiative uh comes first and
and our response comes second that's
that's the grammar of being and the
Theologian is tempted to change that
grammar of being and play God and and
almost call God into existence through
his Concepts
that's the great danger of being a mere
theologian
so this idea here this is another idea
that's relevant on the on the issue of
the question of whether what needs to be
put in the highest place is a spirit or
description so the other thing that I
found very much characteristic of
thinkers like Harris and Dawkins and
this is probably even more true of
Harris because Sam Harris is extremely
obsessed by the idea of radical evil
which he believes in devoutly I would
say and has been looking for a means of
producing let's say an objective
morality as a Counterpoint to the
existence of absolute evil as manifested
let's say in genocidal atrocity and so
in some sense it's it's it's accurate to
say that his heart is in the right place
but but like stemming off from that is
this observation which is that
Harris and Dawkins and scientists of
their ilk also
implicitly accept the idea I believe
that truth
has to be nested inside love
because the the the governing idea
behind the scientific Endeavor is that
we're striving for prediction and
control to bring about something like
life more abundant to make life better
and so I read this book a while back
that was written by an ex-kgb agent and
he discussed the Soviet attempt
scientific attempt
to produce a hybrid between Ebola and
smallpox and then to aerosolize it as a
weapon and so it would be extremely
deadly and extremely transmissible and I
was thinking well
from a mere technical perspective how to
hybridize Ebola and smallpox is a
perfectly valid
scientific question
and so then the question is well why not
do it
and and the answer to that has to be
something like well it's wrong
it's clearly wrong this is a bad idea
and so what that also means is that when
scientists attention is directed towards
a given set of phenomena and they
undertake an investigation
in order to be properly motivated
scientifically and I think
psychologically as well they have to be
operating on the assumption that this
search for knowledge is going to be
beneficial to humanity in the
particulars and in the generalities and
so that's a orientation that's
essentially predicated on love and that
truth the scientific truth has to be the
handmaiden of that broader ethical
concern does that seem reasonable to you
it's reasonable unless you are someone
like Karl Marx who once said that his
favorite line in all of human literature
is from gerta's Faust where
Mephistopheles the devil utters these
words everything that exists deserves to
perish
uh that is that is what I would call
absolute evil
I can't I can't believe that you know
because that's a phrase that I've used
repeatedly in my lectures because
Mephistopheles actually say that twice
he says it in the first there's two
there's two uh books to Faust uh written
very far apart in girth's life uh when
he was a young man and then when he was
a much older man and he has
Mephistopheles utter that Credo
in two different forms and he he
basically says elaborate on what you
said that Mephistopheles position is
that it's like Ivan karamazov in the
brothers karamazov he says life is so
Rife with catastrophe and suffering
betrayal malevolence it's so
intrinsically
unworthy that it would be better if
Consciousness itself was just brought to
an end
and I didn't know that Marx made
reference to that that's absolutely
stunning because it is the core ethos of
mephistic of Mephistopheles and so a
core satanic ethos let's say that be
that non-being is better than being it
also contradicts these statements in
Genesis this is something very striking
about Genesis which of course you no
doubt know is that when God steps
through the days of creation using the
word to engender order out of chaos he
insists after each phase let's say that
what has been created is good
so not merely that it exists but that
its existence is good and that that
goodness is preferable to
to non-being and so one of the issues
that I've struggled with is the notion
that
part of what the biblical narrative does
is outline for its adherence
a pathway of existence and perception so
of action and perception and social
interaction
that enables that best enables our
participation in creation to be the good
that overcomes suffering and malevolence
and not just the good that overcomes
suffering but the good that overcomes
evil
uh there's two very different kinds of
evil the the evil that we do that we're
responsible for and then there's the
evil that we suffer harm
uh and the human heart wants both it
wants to love and be loved it wants to
be good and experience good
and if the truth is that those two
things are impossible together if if
if evil is stronger than good and not
surrounded by good if in other words the
benevolent God uh who created the
universe is a myth
uh and the universe is the the ultimate
being and there's nothing Beyond it
then the universe is very much like Red
Butler in Gone With the Wind and says to
us frankly my dear I just don't give a
damn it's Beyond Good and Evil
uh and and
I don't know if there's a proof that
such a God exists or not but it's
certainly an option it's it's a Pascal's
wager you can believe that in the mind
of God there is a adequate and more than
adequate reason why God allows these
horrendous evils even though he can
miraculously stop them
or you can believe that there is no such
reason
uh and I I love Pascal because he's very
practical he says well uh you you you
cannot be refuted whichever of those two
Wagers you you pick there is such a God
there is not such a God but look at the
consequences for life
even if you're wrong uh your life is
Meaningful and it gives you hope and it
gives you uh order uh
and if you're right uh then you'll find
out in the end that uh you were on the
true path and if you're wrong uh well
maybe at the moment of death you'll find
out that it was all an illusion but even
the the the good illusion is better than
nothing
well let's let's take a a kierkega
guardian Twist on that I noticed that
you all have also written about
Kierkegaard and correct me if I'm wrong
but this is what I derived from
Kierkegaard
so
because Kierkegaard talks about this
idea of being a knight of faith
and he's classed with the Christian
existentialists as a consequence of the
practicalities of his view he basically
puts forward a proposition that I think
is akin to the proposition that
undergirds marriage which is
you cannot find out and that this is
relevant to Pascal's wager you cannot
find out whether creation as such is
good or evil without being all in on
your bet just like you can't be married
without saying well I'm shackling myself
to you and I'm not going to run away no
matter what so we better get to know
each other and get along because this is
how it's going to be and without that
you can't be deeply committed enough to
the marriage to make it work so it seems
to me on the on the front of the
Forefront of Faith which is you have to
act in the world with courageous trust
not naive trust but courageous Trust
in the potential goodness of being in
order to actually discover whether or
not that faith is Justified and so the
and that's partly why it's faith is that
you have to put the cart before the
horse
you can't wait around you know in in in
in the Book of Revelation when Christ
comes back to judge everyone
he says something like
um
if you were neither hot nor cold I will
spit you out of my mouth and so his
harshest judgment isn't reserved for
outright unrepentant committed sinners
and certainly not for people who are 100
committed to the courage of their faith
but
to the judgment is harshest for people
who play both ends against the middle
and who won't commit and one of the
things that I've started to toy with is
the idea that faith is actually
a
subset in some sense of of existential
courage
you know I I've talked to my listeners
and viewers about the notion that
if you want to pursue the good
you do that in some sense despite so if
you're naive you're good because you
think everything is good and everyone is
good but if you're naive
you're immature and you're unwise and
then you get jolted out of that naivety
by betrayal and tragedy and then you
become or you're tempted by cynicism and
the cynicism is wiser than the than the
ignorant naivety but it's it's not good
it's the desert let's say it's the it's
the uh it's the Exodus desert after the
tyranny of naivety the and the way out
of that is to events a courageous faith
and the courageous faith is something
like I'm going to do good
despite the evidence for tragedy and
malevolence and the atrocity of history
and all of that and that's part of the
courage of faith I'm going to commit
myself to this and and that in some
sense bypasses Pascal's wager because it
doesn't even have anything to do in some
sense with
what would you say your own Redemption
it's a decision about how to be in the
face of the catastrophe of life and you
have to make a decision one way or
another because you're either going to
take the mephistophilian route and say
you know life is so terrible that it
should just come to an end and that if
there is a God he should be damned for
having the presumption to make such a
terrible world or you're going to say no
despite everything I'm going to work in
all possible ways to make everything
better and to tell the truth while
moving forward and I'm going to conduct
my life according to those principles
and then I'm going to have the adventure
that comes along with that and see what
happens that's what the scientific
atheist does not understand I think that
there are some truths that you cannot
simply discover you have to live them
you have to make the experiment
uh I think of kindergarten's night of
Faith from the Viewpoint of Juliet Here
Comes Romeo with no guarantees he does
not bring an uh an array of lawyers and
philosophers to persuade her that it is
utterly rational for her to elope with
him he says leap into my arms
and she does not know whether that will
end well or not
uh it it's an Act of Faith it's a leap
and in the play of course it doesn't pay
off they both die or you might say that
even even that since it was an in a
sense a noble death was a payoff but uh
but there's no guarantee that's that's
why there's Faith yeah well there's this
idea idea from the materialist
determinists let's say that if we just
derived enough information about the
nature of things that we could produce
an algorithm that would enable us how to
compute our movement forward now that is
nice
it is naive well I think it's
technically naive because I've talked to
some great scientists like sir Roger
Penrose and Penrose believes that in
principle The Horizon of the future is
not fundamentally predictable from the
positions of the past from
so what this is not a Clockwork universe
that the Horizon of that what we've
confront is a horizon of potential which
I think of as somewhat equivalent to the
chaos that God confronted at the
beginning of time that we confront this
potential that has multiple potential
branches which is the way that the world
could array itself as a consequence of
our decision and that we impose a vision
on that
and that vision is a production of faith
and then we enact the vision and that
enacting is a an Act of Faith and that's
well that's part of what's attracted me
to the existential thinkers let's say
rather than the scientific materialist
determinists I would not use the word
impose I would use the word add whether
the universe is a Clockwork universe or
not doesn't much matter because our
lives are not Clockwork lives so that we
can
add to the universe new data by our
choices by our by our living and what
effect that has on the Universe I don't
know I don't know if the stars tremble a
little bit when we love each other more
or not I suspect that there's some
connection because
spiritual gravity and physical gravity
have to be at least analogous And if
every particle of matter in the universe
is relative to every other particle of
matter in the universe why shouldn't
every particle of Personality every
individual human being and their choices
and their loves and hates also have
effects on everyone that's the Russian
concept of subordinast which is so
strong in Dostoyevsky especially the
brothers karamazov I love Ivan karamazov
he's my favorite atheist
he's passionate he's committed he's
moral he's a moral atheist he's not an
amoral atheist
right well and he's admirable and and
he's charismatic and he's he's good
looking and I mean one of the things
that's so absolutely wonderful about
Dostoevsky which puts him in the top
rank of of all-time Geniuses I actually
prefer Dostoevsky to Nietzsche in the
final analysis I would say
um although it's a tight battle
um is that when he makes an atheist when
dostoysky makes an atheist he pulls out
all the plugs man and so I know in the
brothers karamazov Ivan wins pretty much
all of his arguments with eliosha
because he's so articulate and so able
to put forward his his claims although
eliosha beats him on the character
illogical side which is one of the Great
what would you say brilliant
um literary accomplishments of
Dostoevsky it's really something I don't
think anyone in history has ever written
con uh
fiction about Jesus which which moves
you except Dostoevsky and in the grand
Inquisitor Jesus says nothing and does
nothing except for that kiss and that's
sufficient
and it looks as if Ivan won the argument
earlier than that because I even got
elyosha to admit if you were God and you
were creating a universe and you gave
man free will and you saw that it would
inevitably uh result in these Horrors
these these parents who are torturing
their children would you consent to be
the architect and right El Joshua who's
utterly honest says no I wouldn't
consent
so there is an Ivan in alyosha there is
a rebel in us and it's a good rebel
uh God approves job's Rebellion rather
than the three friends uh comfort
at the end of The Book of Job God says
an amazing thing he says uh to the three
friends uh I I burn with anger against
you because you have not spoken rightly
about me as my servant job has
but what they said was simply Orthodox
it's it's in the rest of the Bible God
is great and God is good let us thank
him for our food amen and job who
admitted that his words were wild
because the sufferings were so great
it's accusing God and wishing that he
could take him to court
and yet God approves that honest
Rebellion on job's part rather than the
uh a comfortable acceptance on the part
of the three friends
dostoevski must have loved that
right while job is at least wrestling as
honestly as possible with the issues of
tragedy and malevolence he's he's facing
that four square and and I would suspect
that the reason to put words in God's
mouth that job is approved of is that
the more naive uh advocates for God's
goodness are merely avoiding looking at
the Calamity and catastrophe and
protecting themselves in that way but
that means a real faithlessness in some
profound sense because as Nietzsche
pointed out I suppose is that there's
some real utility in staring into an
abyss and Nietzsche warned right if you
stare into an abyss the abyss might
stare into you and that if you fight
with monsters you risk becoming a
monster and that's an extremely wise
caution but one of the things I've sort
of sorted out in relationship to the to
the crucifixion image is that the
crucifixion image and the passion story
in some real sense and I'm speaking
psychologically here not religiously at
least to begin with is the ultimate
Abyss because it brings together all the
elements of unfair suffering that might
characterize life or that do
characterize life it brings them
together in a single story and then it
makes the claim that if you gaze upon
that image with sufficient intensity and
duration and perhaps Faith which you
have to have in order to gaze upon it at
all is that what you end up seeing and
contemplating is not death and hell but
the resurrection and the overcoming of
death in hell and you know one of the
things clinicians have learned in the
last hundred years perhaps above all
else maybe they learned two things is
that honest dialogue
promotes
health and redeems and that's the first
thing and the second thing is
if you face what
disturbs you and forces you into
paralysis and avoidance and tyranny if
you face that four
forthrightly and voluntarily that that
will
ennoble your character and help you grow
and so a lot of what a clinician does is
take a fear that someone might have
that's paralyzing them and then break it
down into small subsets sort of like the
brick in relationship to the cathedral
and then have people practice voluntary
confrontation and what inevitably
happens is not that people get less
afraid but that they become braver and
more competent
and so then you might say if you tied
that back into this idea of the evil
that besets creation and the notion of
human free will you might say that
the universe is constituted such that
it's a greater good that evil can exist
as a possibility and that it's a greater
good that human beings have free will
than that they're compelled slaves and
the downside of that is that we can
freely choose evil
and then that accounts for the permi the
pervasive evil that characterizes human
endeavor and the cosmos in some sense
but that a world without that
possibility because it would involve
pure subjugation and no choice and no
voluntary ascent and no real Destiny a
world without that would be a much
lesser place because one of the things
you can say is that
it's possible that God left human being
something important to do yes and that's
very good Theology and very good
apologetics uh and even in a sense
justifying the ways of God to man but
that's not yet religion that's still I'm
in the driver's seat and I'm making the
road maps and I'm traveling on this
journey and I'm making my life
meaningful and I'm making my character
honest and courageous and that's all
very good but that's not yet abrahamic
theism that's Norse mythology
uh maybe the guys will go down into
defeat maybe evil is stronger than good
well then let's go down in defeat on the
right side because right is more
important than might
and and that's Noble that's that's the
second best thing in the world but then
you have the resurrection then you have
the God who who adds power to his
goodness and his love
so you have it all together
uh but that has to come from God not
from us
so our response to that has to be
secondary it has to be a response we
don't impose that upon the universe we
don't read our our faith into the
universe
we we we see we we are Juliet and we see
Romeo coming with this marriage proposal
and we say yes to it like the Blessed
Virgin Mary you know Fiat be it done
unto me according to your will that's
the essence of religion and that's why I
love Islam it's so simple it's it's so
so centered on on absolute surrender and
submission okay so a couple of things to
tie together there so when Nietzsche
announced the death of God he he
formulated another proposition he said
that we may have to become Gods merely
to atone for the sin of of of of of of
uh
deicide and so he believed that the over
man the Superman would be someone who
through the power of his own will set
his own values now I spent a lot of time
reading Jung Carl Jung
in relationship to Nietzsche uh Jung for
example published a
must be it
1500 page two-volume book on the first
third of thus spake zarathustra and was
a very deep nietzschean scholar and but
fell under the influence of Freud and
this turned out to be of cardinal
significance because Freud
was the one of the first secular
thinkers to note that in some
unbelievably fundamental sense we are
not Masters in our own house
there are sub personalities within us
there are complexes within us there are
angels and demons within us that's
another way of thinking about it and
they pull us this way and that
sometimes independent of her will and
often contrary to our will and so
Freud's conclusion was it's very
difficult for human beings to create
their own values because we have an
intrinsic nature that's not subject to
our arbitrary will and then Jung took
that a step further and he said well
there's no doubt that we act out a myth
and a story and that in the deepest
sense that has to be a theological story
and that some the spirit that guides us
has to have a unitary nature which he
did associate with Christ quite
explicitly and it was a it's a vicious
rejoinder to the nietzschean presumption
that we can create and impose our own
values for for the psychoanalysts those
values and I would say for for the wise
clinicians those values have to be
discovered not
not self-generated and imposed plus you
just don't live long enough to do that
you're just not wise enough to generate
a whole system of universally applicable
values out of whole cloth in the span of
your trivial life and if you know you're
doing that then you reduce life to a
game you you have created the meaning of
life well who is the creator
you what what what gives you the right
to do that what gives you the power to
do that you did not create the universe
how can you write the laws of morality
any more than you can write the laws of
physics well it's it's also people find
that shallow you know in my clinical
work I saw this
time and time again so if I was dealing
with someone who was suffering you know
maybe they had a tragedy in their own
life a medical tragedy or a medical
tragedy among members of their family or
maybe they had been subject to some
really vicious malevolent actors and
they were despairing they had to
discover the values that would lift them
out of that catastrophe they couldn't
impose them and and it's a real search I
think this is probably related to your
work on prayer it's a real search and
one of the things I used to counsel my
clients uh about and I also built a
program called self-authoring that helps
people do this is and this is associated
with that biblical injunction in the New
Testament to knock and have the door
open and to ask and to receive and to
seek and to find is that you can have a
dialogue and interior dialogue that
precedes something like this and I think
it's a prayer which is okay I understand
because I'm reasonably mature that there
is a tragic and malevolent element to
life and it's deep enough to destabilize
me and to upset my faith in existence
itself
is there a path that I could walk down
that would be so rich and meaningful
that I would find the challenge of
dealing with the tragedy in malevolence
ennobling and worthwhile and then it's a
search you think well what what would
what would be of sufficient value to
offer that possibility and people find
that in they find it in love they find
it in family they find it in Friendship
they find it in sacrificial occupation
let's say they find it in Beauty but
these aren't created values they're
discovered values
and and then you bring yourself into
alignment with them that's when you
wrote your book on Islam one of the
things that you had to say about Islam
that was very
um
laudatory was that the Islamic people
have appeared to do a better job of
insisting that human beings are
subordinate to the Divine will in this
in the sense I think in the in the best
sense in this sense of discovery that
we're talking about
especially in Europe and North America
we have this obstacle about an obsession
with freedom and a misunderstanding of
freedom
uh we are not totally free our freedom
in every sense is limited we are finite
uh and we don't like that we we we want
to play God with regard at least to
freedom and autonomy
uh
that's maybe the biggest difference
between modern western civilization and
all others in in world history we could
think about that freedom you know
because it isn't so let's say here's the
claim I want to be free to do what I
want
okay well hang on a sec which eye are
you talking about there are you talking
about the mature eye that sees next week
and next month the next year and 10
years out and it takes the community
into account or are you talking about
the impulsive hedonistic self-serving
narrow eye that just wants exactly what
it wants right now and what makes you
think that when you make a case for that
Hedonism that you're not just falling
under the sway of an impulsive
short-sighted demon so to speak
you know this and then I used to play
this game with my students
um when we were talking about ordered
freedom and that the notion that freedom
itself has to be ordered
um I think I mentioned earlier that when
God calls his people out of tyranny he
says that they need to be free in order
to serve him in the wilderness not to be
free in some absolute sense so I used to
play a game with my students I I'd go up
to one student I'd say do you want to
play a game
put him on the spot and he'd say yes and
I'd say okay
you'll move first
and that would paralyze the student into
absolute immobility because he was now
faced with a plethora of choices so
utterly broad that there was no pathway
forward and that was part of a
discussion about the fact that
if you look at music for example music
operates by very sophisticated rules and
so it's ordered and constrained but out
of that rules system of rules comes in
almost infinite array of possibility and
so you know we have this sense I think
it derives from Rousseau that any
constraint of order is a limit on
freedom when what we should be
hypothesizing is that with the optimal
set of principles you get the maximally
desirable freedom and it's not freedom
from everything and it's not freedom to
do anything it's certainly not a narrow
hedonistic freedom because that
backfires on you like the next day yes
if there is no world outside of Plato's
Cave then it is not freeing to escape
from the cave
uh there's certainly a great value to
Freedom uh we must be free from
everything that that opposes us and and
and restrains our our better impulses
but that assumes that there's a better
and a worse that assumes that there's
something like Plato's the good outside
the cave so you can be free right from
from the Shadows of the cave and that
notion of of of Freud that there are a
lot of people inside of us uh good ones
and bad ones a little good in the in the
worst of us and a little bad of the best
of us so that it all becomes the worst
of us to speak well of the best of us uh
that's from Thornton Wilder I think uh
that's very helpful because when you
talk to atheists you're talking to not
just one person but many persons uh one
of the things that shocked me the most
in talking to atheists was that when I
when I give them something like the
argument from desire don't you at least
wish there was a God don't you at least
see religion as a an attractive fairy
tale don't you at least hope that it's
true even though you don't believe that
it's true almost always they say no
I don't want there to be a God I don't
want there to be a heaven
uh I I
I would be threatened by that
uh and I think they're suppressing
something I don't think the human heart
is that different between an atheist and
a theist the human heart was not
designed at Harvard or Hollywood it was
designed in heaven so we all want
the thing we can't Define uh we're all
Mystics deep down we want we want
unlimited goodness truth and Beauty this
is definitely the case I mean I would
say in some sense by definition is that
the most profound Goods
are reflected in the structure of the
human heart if people are striving
forward and I mean forward rather than
downward let's say forward and Uphill
they are by definition pursuing
something that's a reflection of a
Transcendent good it's Transcendent
because if they already had it which
means it would be imminent if they
already had it they wouldn't have to
pursue it they posit something outside
of themselves as better and then the
ultimate definition of that in some
sense is the pursuit of the divinely
good
and again I see that as a matter of
definition and so now you know on the
atheist front I've read a lot of
comments from atheists in my YouTube
comment sections on my biblical lectures
I probably read at least hundreds of
them and maybe thousands of them but at
least hundreds and one of the things
that has struck me continually is that
many of the people who become
atheists are reaction are reactionary
and I don't mean that in a denigrating
sense
a huge proportion of people who are
stridently atheistic were hurt very
badly by people who purported to be
religious when they were young and I
think that also applies to Dawkins by
the way uh I've seen some some evidence
for that in his public utterances and so
you have people who've been terribly
betrayed by what by the Agents of what
was supposed to be the best and so they
carry that utter bitterness with them
that ultimate betrayal because I think
there isn't anything worse in some sense
than being betrayed by people who claim
to be acting let's say in Christ's name
I mean how could anything be worse than
that and so then they're driven to this
atheism and they're so afraid then again
to re-establish a new Faith because
they've been hurt so badly that they're
willing to suffer this purgatorial
drought of vision rather than to put
themselves up on the chopping block one
more time wasn't Freud himself an
example of that didn't he have a very
bad relationship with his father and
Kendra use a fruit and Analysis to
explain Freud
well that that you can imagine too at a
theological level because especially in
the abrahamic Traditions God is
construed as a paternal spirit in some
fundamental sense I know it's
complex when you get to the highest
level of abstraction but and what that
would also mean was that if you had an
impaired relationship with your father
or with the patriarchal spirit in
general that that's going to put a
resentful twist in your relationship to
the
eternal spirit as such and I certainly
see that as well it's something that
bedevils our current society as well
because there's so much objection to the
patriarchal system and the catastrophic
atrocities of history and the
fundamental and unreliability of the
paternal or patriarchal spirit that all
of that is tied together and it is tied
together with the problem of sin you
know a lot of women who object
strenuously to the patriarchy let's say
are also simultaneously women who have
been rendered bereft of any positive
relationship with any man even once in
their whole life yes yes yes I have
found that too in my limited experience
and I think the only adequate answer to
that is is not merely psychoanalysis and
understanding but alyosha's kiss
to experience genuine love to meet a
Mother Teresa that will convert you much
faster than all the arguments in the
world right well that's and that's
really the theme in some profound sense
both of the brothers karamazov and of
the idiot because the great characters
the the heroes of both of those novels
eliosha in the one and and mishkin and
the other is that despite their relative
lack of facility with delineated
abstract arguments even in favor of the
existence of God their character is such
that they're very being stands as the
best proof of their beliefs and that
seems to me to be a Way Forward too in
this Interfaith dialogue you know I
talked to a relatively
fundamentalist Islamic leader a young
leader Muhammad hijab in the UK and uh
we were talking about the use of
compulsion in faith and
I was trying to sort out how the
different doctrines might compete and
cooperate with one another going forward
especially in the face of this secular
Onslaught which I think is the worst
threat that any of the abrahamic
religions currently confronts is that it
should be something like a competition
of invitation it should be something
like Let The Best Man win and that would
mean that an adherent of a given Faith
let's say Orthodox Christianity or
orthodox
Judaism or or Islam is that the people
who abide by those faiths should be such
Stellar examples of a light shining on
the hill that people are convinced of
the validity of the belief by the
Exemplar of the practitioners and that's
the right place to have a what do you
call that
what's the Islamic word for holy war
Jihad Jihad that's the proper Jihad yes
exactly a competition of invitations and
I think that ties into the Old Testament
biblical notion of radical Hospitality
so one index of that would be well how
well do you treat strangers for example
or how well do you treat women that
might be a good example as well
I think God has set the world up in such
a way that that necessarily happens the
religion that produces the most Saints
will make the most converts now you were
in it you this book on Islam you wrote
you you you went out of your way to be
positively oriented towards Islamic
belief and practices now you delineate
the differences between Islamic belief
and Christian belief let's say but
nonetheless you make a strong case that
the Islamic world has something to teach
the secular and Christian world so would
you mind elaborating on that a little
bit why did you do that and what did you
conclude
it seems to me that when I look at
Christianity in Western culture you're
up in North America uh I see a kind of
of nice spinelessness an absence of
Courage when solianism came to America
and gave that great Harvard commencement
address in 1978 one of the great
speeches in the history of Western
Civilization I think he said he said I I
noticed something lacking here I I
certainly would not recommend the USSR
or communism we are indeed Wicked but at
least we have courage you don't
where are the heroes
for all its mistakes and all its faults
and all its tendency towards violence
and fundamentalism uh at least Islam uh
is a heroic faith
uh it tends to be a bit too hard and and
spiny uh without flesh but we are our
flesh without a spine
I I think we should we we should
exchange uh some of our pop
psychologists for some of their fiery
mullahs
so we got a spine and they get some
flesh well that might be a real positive
outcome for a genuine dialogue I mean
classically God has correct me if if I'm
wrong in my presumptions here but my
understanding is that God has
long been seen to rule with two hands
left and right and the left hand is
Mercy and the right hand is judgment and
that judgment element that's
discrimination that's the ability to
separate the wheat from the chaff that's
the willingness to pluck out an eye if
it if it's corrupting your vision or to
cut off a hand if it's airing right it's
this stringent discrimination between
that which is not worthy and that which
must be retained and it seems to me that
like heaven is definitely a place let's
say where anything unworthy does not
exist and that means that the Judgment
of what is unworthy has to be extremely
painstaking and harsh for anything like
heaven to come about because anything
that isn't Heavenly can't belong there
and so that requires that judgment and
what I'm seeing happening in the west is
that we've we're making the case and I
think this is a feminist case in some
deep sense we're making the case that
the Cardinal moral virtue who is mercy
and forgiveness and forgetting
completely about the fact that
well another cardinal virtue is judgment
and that
Mercy I mean Freud knew this right with
and this is the Brilliance of his
Insight with regards to the edible
complex you know he he regarded
biologically he thought
well human beings have this unbelievably
protracted period of dependence and
they're basically born in some sense
feel
so there's an evolutionary arms race
between the width the circumference of
an infant's head and the hole in the
pelvic floor that enables women to give
birth and there's been a bunch of
compromises so to speak to make birth
possible one is the baby's head is
compressible which is quite the uh
needle to thread let's say women's hips
are wider almost wide enough so that
they're impaired in their ability to run
if they were any wider they couldn't run
well and uh
and the babies are born much earlier
than they would be typically for a
mammal of our size
and so and then human beings have this
immense capacity for socialization and
particularized development and so
they're extremely dependent not only in
that first postnatal period the first
year let's say when they should still be
gestational in some real sense but then
for 18 years after well they're being
socialized and that brings up a danger
and the danger is that
the
all-encompassing love that's properly
devoted to an individual to a to an
infant
will be sustained longer than it should
be and become a devouring Force
and so the psychoanalyst I think it was
Freud who famously said the good mother
must necessarily fail
it's like the paella Michelangelo's
paella you know Mary offers her son to
be broken by the world which is a real
Act of Courage on the part of women but
it also means that they can't be and
neither can fathers for that matter they
can't be entirely merciful and forgiving
because that's good for infants but it's
not good for people who are developing
you have to bring judgment into the
equation and that starts as soon as the
child starts to mature and one of the
things our civilization lacks is a a a
ceremony of adulthood a a a a harrowing
uh courage inspiring transition from
that infantile to to adult
responsibility
uh that has to somehow be restored well
anthropologists have have remarked upon
that so the idea there is well girls
mature earlier than boys and they hit
the menstrual cycle and they are subject
to pregnancy and so in some sense nature
comes pouring in brutally for women at
about the age of 12 or 13. and so
there's a cut off there between
childhood and maturation that's very
Market that would be the onset of
menstruation but for men that's not the
same and anthropologists have noted that
many
initiation rituals among archaic people
involved something that looks like
uh ritual duplication of the onset of
menstruation so you get penile
sub-incision for example which is quite
a brutal practice but it is a it is a
initiation in blood
or the boys will be taken away from
their mothers when they're 12 or 13
let's say and the mother's put up quite
a bit of fuss and make quite a show of
their sorrow for losing their child and
then they're taken away by the men and
put through a Baptist like a uh what
would you call it a radical baptism
where they force where their previous
identity and they learn to consciously
abide by the masculine traditions of the
society and many many societies have
evolved or produced or
spontaneously and wisely generated these
rituals of maturation and they
definitely the closest we have probably
is high school graduation but it's
it's shallow in some in some deep sense
would you say that uh in an unconscious
attempt to substitute for that we form
gangs and perform acts of violence
against Society
is that part of the explanation for it
well yes look here here's an interesting
case example of that so elephants are
extremely social and the males can be
quite aggressive the young ones in
particular and that's particularly the
case under sexual uh motivation in the
case of sexual motivation let's say if
you take an elephant herd and you kill
off all the old males then the young
males basically become anti-social and
criminal among the elephants and what
happens among young men is if they don't
have older men to guide them is they do
spontaneously form gangs in an attempt
to separate themselves from their from
the maternal influence that happens in
teenage hood you know when for every
teenager the friends become more
important than the parents and that's
how it should be because the Friendship
group is this intermediary stage toward
full adult development so you get these
gangs and then the gangs do do
tests of courage and toughness and they
can degenerate into a kind of
blood-letting brutality without that
wisdom of guidance that would be
provided by by Elder men so what has to
be done then is to somehow combine this
Justice and this Mercy this toughness
and this tenderness this uh patriarchal
and matriarchal uh and isn't the
Christian answer to that precisely the
crucifixion
here here is Justice and mercy United
Thomas Aquinas wrote his uh uh his
initial uh I don't know what it was the
technical term was uh I got him a
theological degree on the verse Justice
and mercy will meet uh
uh compassion and truth will will will
join hands because truth will Spring
both from the earth and uh from the
heavens
here you have uh the ultimate uh justice
being done the the the ultimate judgment
on sin the horror and uh the motivation
for that is the total Mercy the the the
infinite Mercy uh simultaneously well
there's some there's there's something
to that so so tell me what you think
about this so in this Exodus seminar
one of the things we talked about okay
this is complicated
So This brilliant scholar Jonathan
paggio
brought up an issue with regard to the
pillars of fire and the pillar of cloud
that guides the Israelites through the
desert okay so you leave a tyranny
and you don't go to the promised land
you leave a tyranny it might be the
tyranny of your own presumptions but you
leave a tyranny
and you end up in the desert
and the desert isn't a lot preferable to
the Tyranny and so that knowing that is
a good is is very useful in helping you
understand why people won't drop their
own tyrannical presuppositions because
it doesn't free you to begin with it
puts you in the desert okay now what
should guide you in the desert well a
pillar of fire at night and a pillar of
cloud during the day and pajo said and I
thought this was stunningly brilliant he
said that's analogous to the black dot
in the white Paisley and the white dot
in the black Paisley in the Taoist yin
and yang
and that the idea is that there's
there's light in the darkness and
there's shade and cool and darkness in
the light and the balanced interplay
between those provides Divine guidance
so it's like the interplay between Chaos
and Order and that provides Divine
guidance in the desert and so
that
okay now take that now imagine those two
pillars now step back in The Exodus
story briefly and think about the
Passover so you have the lintel and
there's two pillars one on each side
and then God asks the Israelites to Mark
the the space between the lentils with
the blood of the innocent that's the
lamb and so then there's an idea this is
an unbelievable idea that
the innocent must be sacrificed in a
meaningful way in order for the spirit
of for in order for us to escape God's
rebuke to the tyrant
and so Christ is the sacrifice of the
innocent you think what does that mean
why does the innocent have to be
sacrificed and it has to it has to be
something like
well
imagine that you're living a good life
and that you're trying to be a good
person and so you're striving towards a
kind of Innocence you still have to
sacrifice yourself to life you have to
accept mortality you have to accept
malevolence you have to be willing to
undertake the sacrifice of the innocent
in order for life itself to continue
and so and that's the story that's
crucial a crucial central element of the
passion right because Christ is a
sinless
being and he takes the full weight of
existence upon himself voluntarily and I
can't help but think that that's
something that's incumbent on all of us
is that we're all subject to betrayal
we're subject to the Mob we're subject
to the dictates of tyrants we have to
sacrifice our own innocence as well as
our guilt in order for life to Prevail
we have to bear all that weight that's
the cross in the most fundamental sense
and that weirdly enough that does unite
mercy and judgment because to the degree
that you're willing to act as a
sacrifice to the Lord
then life optimizes around you and
because it's a radical acceptance of of
the preconditions of existence tragedy
and malevolence and that works it's very
practical that just to go back to the
idea of what's practical
the only alternative to that would be
the Triumph of evil or the conquest of
Evil by force
but once you conquer Evil by force you
yourself always become corrupt if you
conquer evil instead by by this
strange joining of of mercy and Justice
then you're like uh you're like the lamb
the innocent lamb uh who defeats the
dragon uh to use the imagery from The
Book of Revelation uh arnian means we
little lamb and therion is is horrible
Beast uh and here is is all of human
life at stake uh the heavyweight
championship of the universe and the
lamb wins by his blood
that's a secret weapon well okay well
well it you know it does you you know
you you might say well in order to keep
the dragons at Bay
the thorns and the serpents at Bay we
have to make sacrifices now that's the
first one of the first ideas that
emerges in the stories of Genesis
because once Adam and Eve are
divorced from Paradise they have to toil
and so that's where the sacrificial idea
of first comes in and then in the next
book you have Cain and Abel and it's a
book about
proper and improper sacrifice and Cain's
sacrifices are somehow second rate and
rejected by God and because of that
rejection Cain becomes embittered and
homicidal and his descendants become
genocidal whereas Abel makes the highest
possible quality sacrifices and as a
consequence he's favored of God and so
then you think okay well do we believe
any of that it's like well
we know perfectly well that if we make
sacrifices with blood in them that were
more likely to be successful right if we
go all in if we don't hold anything back
if we commit 100 if we try as hard as we
can the probability that we will succeed
is much higher and we know that if we
hold back and offer second-rate
sacrifices and try to pull the wool over
our own eyes and that of others and that
of God that we're going to be rejected
and fail everyone knows that
and so then it begs another question
which is okay well you have to make the
highest possible sacrifice the highest
possible quality sacrifice and that has
to be your willingness to sacrifice
yourself like what else could it be if
there's no greater sacrifice than that I
mean maybe you could argue that a mother
allowing her child to mature and be
broken by the world is an equivalent
sacrifice I think you could make that
case but fundamentally you don't have
anything to offer more profound than
yourself and then maybe even more than
that you don't have anything to
sacrifice more profound and more
valuable than your own innocence
and I think we all know that this does
not depend upon uh one religion or
another religion in in the Harry Potter
series I know a lot of Christians don't
like it because uh his author is not a
Christian but I think the morality there
is very Christian Harry sacrifices
himself
that's profoundly Christian
absolutely uh oh yes well that that
whole series is amazingly uh profound
archetypally she has it
unerring religious imagination and you
can tell that because why else would
have she been able to get
hundreds of thousands millions of young
people to read a sequential
array of 600 page books
obviously she tapped into something and
I mean the second volume is pretty much
a straight retelling of Saint George and
the Dragon and it's brilliantly
structured mythologically and it's
clearly the case that Voldemort is a
stand-in for Satan for all intents and
purposes and and that Harry does
undertake a
track and a quest like like Frodo and
Bilbo in the in The Lord of the Rings in
The Hobbit and overcomes evil through
self-sacrifice those two books are
probably the two most popular books in
the English language today and and uh
talking in a more subtle way is saying
the same thing because the three Christ
figures there are are Frodo and Aragorn
and Gandalf all of whom sacrifice
themselves all of whom in different
words in different ways die
uh and Frodo can't can't uh live in the
Shire anymore he's he's uh he can only
be healed in the other place and and
Gandalf actually dies in resurrects and
Aragorn goes through the paths of the
Dead which no other man can do
so there's profoundly Christian imagery
of sacrifice there uh and
our wiser self when when we read that
story uh we can't help
saying yes to it
uh right right we see ourselves well or
or or no yes right because we can reject
it but there's no being ambivalent about
it there's no being not gripped by it
well you see the same thing reflected in
the
um in the New Avengers series you know
which is a profoundly counter-cultural
entertainment series because it's not
woke or at least it what it it except in
in brief on on and what would you call
them unacceptable Snippets the main
character there Iron Man is trying to
transform himself into a being of gold
in for all intents and purposes and he's
he's a sacrificial agent as well like
Icarus he flies up to keep the chatori
from descending upon Earth and their
satanic agents for all intents and
purposes and he sacrifices himself in
doing so and he's an ambivalent
character because he's a bit of a
fascist and he's an arms dealer and so
he's definitely me somebody whose
character is complex let's say he's a
technological intellect as well but
fundamentally he's a sacrificial figure
in the battle between good and heaven or
good and evil in heaven and it's so
interesting to me that we've poured all
these computational resources into
telling those stories because you know a
lot of what drives our
hunger for computational power is our
desire to render
likenesses of the world in a fictional
setting to retail archetypal stories
because we have enough computational
power for most of what we use computers
for but not enough to render potential
alternative worlds with sufficient
degree of accuracy and so I know people
who work very intently on the
technological front and I've asked them
where they access demand for
computational power comes from and it's
all
the desire to render more and more
accurate fictional worlds and they all
have an archetypal structure which is
something like the sacrificial battle in
the constant war between good and evil
it's always something like that
it isn't obvious that we think anything
is more important than that
so do you see even behind the
technological Revolution uh the same
unconscious thirst that uh that
Augustine speaks of the Restless Heart
Is it is it a confused search for God
is isn't there a doubleness there on the
one hand on the on the one hand we want
to be God and play God but on the other
hand we want there to be a god
well I think I think that I mean the
people I know who are operating on the
technological front
the the wise ones are hyper concerned
that this endeavor occurs in a moral
Direction so I know people for example
who are working assiduously to produce
advanced
computer chip technology optimized for
artificial intelligence and they're
getting close to the point where they're
going to produce
computational devices that have the
computing power of a human brain that's
probably only three or four years away
now I could be wrong about that but that
isn't what the calculations
indicate and they're very concerned that
this occurs within a moral rubric and
that fight is going on in so for example
people like Elon Musk who I haven't
spoken to directly he wants to ensure
that the benefits of artificial
intelligence are placed in the hands of
individual people because he's concerned
that if a huge conglomeration like
Google gets artificial intelligence
first that that will turn them into
something approximating the world's most
imaginably effective dictator and so
even on the technological front I mean
it to the degree that we're trying to
modify the world to limit malevolence
and to bring about life more abundant
and to redress suffering all of the
people who are striving forward on that
front who are
far-seeing are very very much concerned
that this
takes place
in the proper relationship to such
things as good and evil but if they're
only notion of Good and Evil is
human happiness uh if what they want
above all is to limit human suffering
and to conquer nature in a baconian and
Faustian and Promethean way uh then this
is not going to succeed until they
conquer death by genetic engineering
which some people I'm told in Silicon
Valley especially the transhumanists say
is is feasible uh if that happens if we
get the immortality Gene
you don't really think that that's going
to make a better world I think that's
going to make a kind of a hell on Earth
because we're designed to were designed
to suffer and sacrifice and break and
learn that way we're like eggs we're
like eggs if you don't if you don't
hatch you go bad rotten yeah I I should
have said unnecessary suffering rather
than suffering per se perhaps
um I I don't many of the people that I'm
talking to aren't Promethean in that
nature in that manner
um they're very cognizant of the
complexities of
the necessity of mortality let's say but
maybe I could ask you a question about
that in terms of visions of heaven so
I've had visions of heaven and one
element of that Vision was that heaven
was a place where everything was perfect
and yet everything within it was
striving to make it even better
and I thought about that musically and
psychologically so you know a great
piece of music in each at each moment is
in some sense as good as it can be but
then it brings forth something
additional that's even better and it
just keeps doing that and that way you
get you know because you could imagine a
state of static Perfection as a heaven
but then you might say well a state of
static Perfection is imperfect because
it's static and so what you want is to
join being and becoming
so that you have a perfect being plus
perfect becoming and so that's a heaven
that just gets more Heavenly as we work
on it
so I'll set that aside for a moment and
then ask you well I'm also curious about
the beatific Vision let's say and about
Notions of Paradise in the land of milk
and honey and say well something beckons
us forward into the future and
do you think do you personally think
that I guess Heaven's something that we
mutually strive to bring about on Earth
you know like in this dialogue we're
having you and I are trying to be as
honest as we can and hopefully we're
trying to aim at the good we're trying
to establish little microcosm of
paradisal interaction in the here and
now and I wonder well
you know I think Christ said the kingdom
of God is spread upon the Earth but men
either cannot or will not see it it's
like
for me I don't know to what degree
Heaven is intermingled in the structure
of the reality that we perceive as
mortal beings and to what degree we can
bring that reality into being as a
consequence of our shared effort well
there's a very obvious and simple answer
to that question just as music is a
better image of Heaven than technology
so human love is an even better image of
Heaven than music in fact it's not an
image it's it's that which Heaven
essentially consists of
uh if you truly love someone you love
them more and more and more every year
despite whatever problem you have
and and and and that's not boring that's
the one thing in human life that doesn't
get boring
because the object is another human
being who is potentially infinite
you can grow forever together
so I asked my parents at one point
um they're in their 80s now
said if you could take a drug that would
restore you to
the health that you
experienced and were blessed with let's
say when you were 18 but you got to keep
the accumulated wisdom
would you do it
and I asked them to think about it
seriously and they were ambivalent about
it and this made me think a lot because
I think of Socrates
apologia and Socrates in his apologia
basically says something like
if you live your life fully
then it would be enough
and so you could imagine
being constrained by our mortal
limitations but exhausting yourself in
the pursuit of your life and emptying
yourself in some consequence maybe what
would you call bringing into being every
jot and Tittle of the law right and not
hiding your light under a bushel but
letting it shine on a hill
and then maybe by the end of your life
you'd look back and you'd say well I did
this I I had my life that that was not
only sufficient but but wonderful and
you could accept death with equanimity
but then I wonder we do have this notion
of Heaven
as characterized by Immortal existence
and so
would it be possible for us to
strive to continually expand our
lifespans and to start living 300 years
or 400 years as we became better and
better at that and then
could it be the case that that would be
a blessing rather than a curse and I
don't know the answer to these things I
think if and only if our quality
increased as well as our quantity that
would work but if it doesn't
if it's 300 more years of the same it
would be oppressive and boring
so I think time itself has to change
after death it's not going to be a
linear time based on the movement of
matter through space
it's got to be a a Kairos a spiritual
time something like the uh the expansion
of music or better the expansion of
human love
look my wife and I are in our 80s and we
fell in love in our 20s and we're both
old and wrinkled now and we love and
respect each other more now than we ever
did before
I think that's the way it has to go you
can't go back
you go forward
how did you manage that how long have
you been married now
almost 60 years
okay so you said that each person and I
I believe this that each person is
associated with the infinite in some
fundamental sense and so there's no end
to the degree that a person can be
discovered or co-discovered and that's
why there's Variety in monogamy if it's
deep there's tremendous variety of
monogamy much more so than serial uh
sexual activity let's say much more and
comparably more what did you do as a
practice you and your wife if you don't
mind me asking that enabled you to say
such a thing after being married for
such a long period of time
it's just a will it's just a resolution
it's just a commitment it's an either or
it's an absolute
you you are the center of my world uh or
you're not and if you are you are
forever
right okay so that's a that's that
that's a decision that's a decision of
Faith a choice to love love is a choice
yes yes right right right okay okay well
this is another thing that I've been
trying to sort out with the atheists
this idea that because their their
criticism of Christianity seems to be
something like well religious faith is
the willingness to suspend rationality
uh and to abide by a set of arbitrary
propositional claims that are analogous
in some sense to a scientific hypothesis
right so you could think about the
biblical creationists in that sense and
I think no no that's not what faith is
Faith is the courage to move forward
in the face of the unknown it's
something like that or faith is the
willingness to make a marital vow
because you don't have the evidence
right you you love this person and I
suppose that's some evidence but then
you decide
For Better or Worse despite our mutual
flaws and inadequacies we're going to
bind ourselves together and then we're
going to make it work and that's a
statement of faith it's not derivation
from the evidence and I think we're
we're and and you said that that served
you well in your marriage in your
married life it's not rational evidence
but in a sense it is evidence because
it's a response to something that's
given that other person is put into your
life by God so as the Jesuits speak
about finding God in all things uh so I
speak of finding God in the other person
of course in in all persons because we
all bear the image of God but especially
in that one person that God has put into
your life as as your one and unique
other yeah well maybe that's the
intimation you know when I I've done a
couple of marriage ceremonies and I've
talked to people about love during those
ceremonies and you know that the classic
evaluative framework for marriages well
you fall in love when you're young and
something like a biologically
instantiated delusion you overvalue the
other person and then that Fades away
and I think no that's not right it's
that love is more like what you see when
you see your children when they're very
young is that you see them clearly and
that's a Grace that there are some
people in your life that you have the
privilege of seeing in something like a
totality and then that manifests itself
as love and then that's a gift that's
given to you and then it can recede
unless you take the steps necessary to
fortify to fortify it and to continually
revivify it so it's like a glimpse of
paradise that love that you fall into
but then you have to earn it like it
recedes and then you have to earn it and
re-establish it it's the primary image
of religion uh it is a choice it is not
a proof it is not a necessity uh it is
not a a substitute for anything else
it's simply a yes or no
uh if they're all or nothing it's it's a
zero-sum game you either play it or you
don't yes yes well that's
yeah that zero-sum game without again as
I said earlier that's part of the reason
I was attracted to Kierkegaard and and
to the existential thinkers the 1950s
existential thinkers in particular
because they weren't they were also much
I suppose in the aftermath of the second
world war they were also like Soldier
knits and very skeptical of a kind of
shallow Hedonism
Soldier knitson's perspective on
Hedonism was well that just disappears
as a orienting strategy the moment the
Jack Boots kicked down your door at
three in the morning it's like but it's
the case if you're right yeah yeah right
or it's the case if you suffer a very
serious illness or someone you love does
or if you're betrayed or or really if
you encounter any of the tragedies of
life it's like that
hedonistic short-term happiness just
disappears and if that's your orienting
God which is something like I suppose
the poor man's dionysius you're just
nowhere as soon as you have trouble it's
not a reliable guide love is a much more
reliable guide and and that bonded faith
in a marriage is a much more reliable
guide this is why in the long run I am
optimistic if Western Civilization like
a spoiled child goes down the drain
something better will replace it
there's a kind of of uh I don't know you
call it a a capitalism of the Spirit uh
that's that's the wrong image because
bad money drives out good I'm saying
that morally good money drives out bad
Hedonism doesn't work
it's self-destructive and if the human
race survives something better will
replace it we will learn well Hedonism
he
he like we look
the effect of positive emotion on
decision making
okay so to pursue Hedonism is to
suppress negative emotion let's say but
also to pursue positive emotion and
those can be technically differentiated
neurologically and psychologically
conceptually they're completely separate
systems they're mutually inhibitory they
run on different biochemical Pathways
what happens when you're hedonically uh
when you're in the midst of a hedonic
experience and the answer is you get
short-term and impulsive
and a lot of the pure operation of the
hedonic system is short-term impulsivity
and so the pathology of Hedonism
technically is Mania and it's the
counterpart to depression let's say and
manic people
they want to do everything at once and
they're unbelievably impulsive and so
they can't make good decisions and you
might say well if your philosophy is
hedonic then whatever makes you happiest
is a good decision but then you see
pathologies of Hedonism that produce
impulsivity and the way out of that is
to recognize that
it's sacrifice that's the right
replacement for Hedonism because
you might say well I should be
self-centered we we talked about this
earlier it's like well do you mean the
self that is going to drink a quart of
vodka tonight and then be hung over
tomorrow or do you mean the self that's
going to sustain itself wisely and
carefully over a 40-year period let's
say in a
properly sustaining marriage
and so it isn't even Hedonism it's
narrow impulsive immature two-year-old
Hedonism and that is not a solution this
is why there are no convincing movies
about heaven because our Hedonism has
generated this notion of Heaven as
Supernatural hedonic pleasure
whether it's the beatific Vision or or
music or or golden streets or whatever
uh we're bored by that that's not it we
don't know what it is but but that's
certainly not what it is problem of
boredom goes goes goes deeper than we
think
well in in Notes from Underground
Dostoevsky Nails this to a because he
says and that's so brilliant he's he's
criticizing the Palace of Crystal which
was a building built in the UK for the
World's Fair and it was the first
modernist building and it was this image
of technological Utopia and material
plenty which which the marxists push as
well and Dostoevsky said what's wrong
with this materialist utopian vision and
he says it so brilliantly with his
bitter and cynical character he says if
you set up human beings so they had
nothing to do but
lie around in warm pools of water and
busy themselves with the propagation of
the race
and eat cakes non-stop so
the land of milk and honey in the
narrowest possible sense the first thing
that we would do is set about the place
smashing it up just so something
unpredictable could happen so that we
would have our adventure and I read that
and I thought man that's so deadly right
is that he said human beings are
ungrateful and we can curse it's the
primary thing that separates us from
animals and that's it's related to the
idea of of eating the fruit in the
garden of of of paradise is that we are
made for a challenge we are made for an
adventure we're not made for this kind
of narrow and local Hedonism it's
demeaning and it's counterproductive and
it isn't rich in the face of tragedy and
malevolence it's a bad solution
yeah William James one of my favorite
philosophers has this reflection on a
Utopian community at Chautauqua New York
which he visited uh for a week and he
was fascinated everything was perfect uh
there were no cops everything was free
the culture was wonderful uh and when he
got back to New York City uh with all
the garbage and all the gunfire he said
now I'm in the real world this is what I
was missing there
uh we're not made for Disney World for
Disneyland no there's something trickly
and sentimental it's like Pleasure
Island in the Pinocchio story right
there's there's this overlay of hedonic
um gratification but underneath that
there's a kind of dark slavery that's
exactly what happens in that movie is
Pinocchio when he's striving to become a
real boy he's enticed by a hedonic
vision and he goes to treasure Pleasure
Island where you can have whatever you
want whenever you want but it's ruled by
someone who wants to turn everybody
who's there into a a voiceless braying
slave one of the most surprising books I
ever read is called city of Joy they
made a very trashy movie out of it but
it's a great book it's by the uh the
same journalist Dominic LaPierre who
wrote is Paris burning and it's about
Calcutta especially about the lepers in
Calcutta who are about the most
miserable people in the most miserable
place on Earth and the title of the book
is quite accurate he found a lot of Joy
among this lowest of the lowest class in
in in in Calcutta simply because they
they loved each other they sacrificed
for each other the the sense of
community that was there uh it didn't
take away the pain but it added a
meaning to the pain that made it
preferable to the pleasures of the upper
class
it was it was convincing because he was
there in detail it it sounds romantic
and impossible and ridiculous
uh and yet it's true the the poor the
poor are happier than the rich look
what's the poorest concert in the world
Africa who Smiles the most Africans
what's the richest subcontinent in the
world Scandinavia who commits suicide
the most Scandinavians
well you see too that often people who
are Tried by fire
discover the deepest association with
meaning precisely under those conditions
and that is analogous to the vision of
the crucifix let's say that you have to
go deep into the darkness and perhaps
hopefully voluntarily before you can see
the brightest of all possible lights and
so this idea that the you know part of
the problem is is you know if you
provide your children with everything
which you could do as a wealthy parent
let's say
you deprive them of deprivation you
deprive them of Adventure you deprive
them of Destiny
and you you remove from them the
necessity of grappling in a manner that
really does make life meaningful you
know one of the things that I've really
noticed in my tours this has been
extremely interesting and heartening is
that
whenever I talk about the Nexus between
responsibility and meaning
the audiences always go dead silent
they're pretty silent during most of the
discussions but that particularly brings
a hush to everyone because it's not a
message that people are receiving
anymore it's like okay life is suffering
and malevolence in in its Essence in
some undeniable sense it may not be only
that but it is undeniably also that and
so you need a sustaining meaning to tide
you over
while you're suffering and while you're
betrayed
and then the question is well where is
the most reliable place to find that
meaning and what answer is
well Hedonism and another answer might
be cynicism and anarchism and and that
sort of wildlife that goes along with
throwing off all constraints and there's
some attraction to that but more
fundamentally if you watch people if you
watch how people actually
respond in times of Crisis they find
that
the responsibilities that they've
undertaken in the past to form
friendships to form Intimate
Relationships to clean up their family
and establish tight bonds to take on
some major burden and make sacrifices in
their life that's where they get all the
meaning
and I can't believe that we don't teach
young people this now
we don't teach them this at all and it's
such a catastrophe and you've taught
young people now for a very long time
and so what's been
what's been great about that and and
what have been the impediments to your
success on that front
I don't really know the meaning of the
word success it's too abstract and
general uh for my liking
uh I just know that the average student
that I get at Boston College is a a mix
a cross-section of some of the best and
some of the not so best in our
civilization and
and they they're hungry they they
realize that they're not being fed
uh which is why they take my courses
it's not they they come in to Boston
College in love with Plato or Augusta or
Aquinas they they they come with a
hunger
and when you give them the old common
sensical philosophers they they eat it
up one of their favorite books is
boethius's consolation to philosophy
it's an utterly unoriginal book it's a
synthesis of Socrates Plato Aristotle
stoics Augustine uh and they find it
astonishingly original because they
haven't been taught this stuff
the same is true of Augustine's
confessions it's a blockbuster book it
it hits them in the heart it's not a
perfect book it's it's a messy book and
this is obscurity in it but it uh it it
it feeds their their unconscious hunger
so all I do is uh I give them the stuff
that's on the shelves that have been
neglected uh I'm I'm I'm not an original
philosopher I'm a a bridge builder a
Matchmaker uh
Joe Joan meet meet Augustine Augustine
me Joan first time I ever told
Augustine's confessions my class asked
me can we can we do journals instead of
taking tests and I said yes and there
were about a dozen people in the class
and we went through nothing but
Augustine's confessions not even the
whole of it we stopped at book 10. uh
and they all wrote journals and every
single one of them was longer than the
confessions itself
that's how deep That's How Deeply
Augustine touched them and one common
note to all of them is uh I never knew
Augustine was that interesting uh I I
took this course on a on a whim and uh
it feeds me
it makes me strong
right right well that's a cardinal
observation there too one of the things
I experimented with I started practicing
this in 1983
I started to notice
probably from Reading I was reading a
lot of psychoanalytic literature a lot
of clinical literature at that time I
started to notice that some of the
things I said made me feel weak and
disjointed and other things
made me feel like I was stepping on
Solid Ground crossing a swamp and I
could feel that like I could really feel
that and I thought okay
well what would happen if I stopped
saying all the things that made me feel
weak and only said the things that made
me feel like I was house unified within
itself
and so I've been practicing that for a
very long time and
the the issue with these great thinkers
that you're describing is that they help
people find those solid Stepping Stones
I mean you're an admirer of
non-Christian philosophers
and so and you just said that well you
you taught used Saint Augustine as an
example but you've also made allusions
to Plato and Socrates let's say
why do you find the non-Christian
philosophers useful and how do you view
that utility in light of your explicit
Christianity Christ has a human nature
as well as a divine nature his divine
nature is unique his human nature is the
opposite of unique so in understanding
human nature you understand one of the
natures of Christ
and if Socrates or Plato or Buddha or
Lao Tzu can give you profound insights
into Universal human nature then as a
Christian I say that is a very Christian
Mission
that he has accomplished are you still
actively teaching yes I don't understand
the concept of retirement why retire
from something that's worth doing
right and and you you mentioned in our
discussion before we started Taping that
you're working on a new book on the
Lord's Prayer this is what your 81st
book that's a lot of books by the way
yeah I've lost count numbers are
meaningless uh I I think two things that
will not exist in heaven are computers
and mirrors
I think we'll look at each other instead
of ourselves and I think we
we will integrate the two hemispheres of
our mind better than we do here
well that looking at other people
instead of ourselves I think that's one
of the tickets to Heaven frankly so this
book this book you're ready now on the
Lord's Prayer why did you decide to
focus a whole book on the Lord's Prayer
and can you tell me a little bit about
what your you investment Thomas Aquinas
says well let's start with can cancer
there's only three great questions what
could I know what should I do and what
may I hope
Aquinas says there's only three things
you need to know uh what truth to
believe in and that's summarizing the
Creed and uh What uh choices to make and
that summarizes in the Commandments and
what to desire and that's summarized in
the Lord's Prayer
so it's all in those three things
so I went through every single word in
the Lord's Prayer to try to find hidden
depths and I found that in those few
words there are
Dimensions that are infinite
the Bible is an amazing book it's it's
it doesn't have an end
it's like an ocean without a bottom
oh you know I I saw a great graphic
representation of the Bible that I
popularized to some degree it showed
every verse
and its relationship to every other
verse
and then a little graph at the bottom
showing how many times that verse was
cross-referenced with other verses in
the Bible and so it's it's literally the
case
apart from the technology that the Bible
was among the first hyperlink texts
because it it densely interpenetrates
itself and it's symphonic in that manner
you know in a great piece of music each
note and each phrase exists in
relationship to the whole and is
informed by the whole and the Bible not
least because of its assiduous and
continual editing and selection has this
hyperlinked depth and so it means that
there's an incredible number of pathways
through the book
because as you know each verse can be
Amplified by relationship to the other
verses that pertain to it and that's
often exceedingly enlightening I found
that a lot in this Exodus seminar that I
just ran in Miami uh some of the people
there had exhaustive knowledge of the
cross-references of each verse and it
was incredibly Illuminating there's a
beautiful Hindu image for that it's a
net of diamonds wherever the interstices
of of the chords meet there's a diamond
and each Diamond reflects every other
diamond right right that is a great
image definitely and that's a musical
image
and there's something like that great
quote from Schindler's List he who saves
One Life Saves the World
that one life mirrors the world right
while in Dostoevsky said something like
that too
um which was
we are not only responsible each of us
for everything we do but responsible for
everything that everyone else yes yes
which is that's really that's a bit much
that whole idea well that's the
universal spiritual gravity whatever you
touch Humanity at one point everything
trembles
right right right well and then
solzhenitzen made much of that in the
gulag archipelago because he talked
about the fact that each person within a
totalitarian system that was willing to
lie
to
to get along was a key actor in The
totalitarian system is that without that
willingness for of everyone to lie at
their own individual level of being the
totalitarian regime could not Prevail
and he also said further and I think
influenced by Dostoevsky that one man
who stopped lying could bring down a
tyranny and you might think well that's
the only way a tyranny has ever been
brought down actually is that someone in
the Tyranny decides not to lie anymore
and so that's extraordinarily
interesting
and so and then is it Saint Augustine
you would know this better than me I
read this beautiful description once of
God which I thought was absolutely
remarkable conceptually which was that
God is a circle
whose circumference is nowhere and whose
Center is everywhere yes yes uh
circumference is nowhere infinite no
limit uh Center is everywhere
omnipresent
God is more present to me says Augustine
than I am to myself
and that's true for everyone and that's
and that's why that that individual
contact with God is why a number of
Russian Orthodox mystics say this it's
become almost a cliche if if you go home
this afternoon and do one deed of
genuine sacrificial charity to your
neighbor the result will be that
hundreds of years from now someone on
the other side of the world that you
never dreamed of will have enough Grace
uh to to overcome his trials and if not
not right if you do one deed of harm to
an innocent human being uh then somebody
in the other side of the world hundreds
of years from now will will fall because
of your fall
right right well I believe that's true I
mean one of the things that my clinical
practice taught me first was no one ever
gets away with anything ever like that
book in the sky upon which everything is
written it's like that's a good enough
description of reality that's the real
meaning of karma yeah right exactly
doesn't mean there's no free will it
means that Free Will is one of the links
in the chain but you throw a ball at a
wall straight it'll come back to you
straight you throw it crooked it'll come
back to you crooked and the same with
everybody else
so let me ask you this
in what Manner has teaching all these
young people made you optimistic and in
what Manner has it made you pessimistic
in in our society today so let's start
with uh let's start with pessimistic and
then end with no let's start with
optimistic it's made me up okay about
individuals individuals can can overcome
the system
It's Made Me pessimistic about the
system because increasingly individuals
are stupid and they don't know it they
don't know their history they don't know
their literature they don't know their
their common sense they don't know their
logic
but when you teach them they gradually
come to to realize it you you see
genuine progress
and I think
this may sound naive but
since light is stronger than darkness
and since good is stronger than evil uh
even in the most desperate human being
there is always the uh that principle
working somehow whatever's going to
happen in the future they can overcome
it there's this there's nothing this
side of death that's not overcomeable
there's always hope love is life There's
Hope
I've I've I've seen students who were
deeply deeply confused
uh and sometimes deeply pessimistic and
sometimes they have overcome that it
takes great courage but it works it
happens
right well you can see people who are
not only conceptually confused but have
been hurt tremendously badly and by
malevolent actors and who've been
fractured and Shattered by that and
whose pessimism and cynicism seems
entirely justifiable given their
experience yet rise up and overcome even
that to become positive players often
under the pressure of artistic Endeavor
I've seen that happen many times but
often also spiritual Endeavor that they
can rise above the catastrophe of their
situation and
and and defy the deterministic Mantra
that
you know garbage in and garbage out and
transform their catastrophe into
something that's unbelievably deep
and and heartening
so I love teaching you know at the
University because I have the same
experiences that
students come in with a veneer of
cynicism but it's a self-protective
veneer and it's not very deep and if you
offer them genuine ideas and let's say
time-tested ideas steeped in the
humanistic and Theological tradition the
philosophical tradition the scientific
tradition for that matter that they're
like well they're like people thirsting
in the desert they take to the water
very very rapidly and can make
unbelievable progress and that was
always a great source of inspiration and
hope to see that that was continually
and repetitively true yes yes but the
system makes it increasingly rare and
difficult the humanities are in steep
Decline and the average reason for
anyone going to college is simply to get
a well-paying job yes which the colleges
also tend to be failing at providing so
oh well these conversations are an
attempt to rectify that to some degree
we do what we can
we do what we can that's right that's
right and we do it hoping that things
will be better rather than worse and so
and they can be and so there's reason to
be optimistic on that front
thank you very much for talking to me
today it's much appreciated and thank
you for shedding the light that you've
shed uh in millions of lives
so to close I I just want to remind
everybody who's watching and listening
that Dr kreef has published some 80
books ranging across an incredibly wide
array of deep topics and so I would
recommend to all of you to check out his
well Wikipedia page is a good start
because all the books are listed there I
would also like to remind people that
I'm going to talk to Dr kreef for
another half an hour on the daily wire
platform site and I'm going to do what I
have been doing on that site which is to
delve a little bit into his
autobiographical background and flesh
out the Contours of his career
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com